hello mina-san
konnichiwa it's me yes another day in
japan
so what do i do when i spend my time
here looking at reddit baby
that's what we're doing here today
because no one's ever done that pushing
the boundaries on what is content here
on youtube
i did find a really interesting well
actually i didn't find it
dave from boyinaband send it to me
arigato gosiama's dave he said with this
really funny
reddit it's called awful taste but
great execution for everything that
displays
quality craftsmanship in the least
elegant way
possible it's basically as if you were
extremely talented at something
that no one cares about that's
essentially this reddit a woman
crocheted
is that how you say that herself and her
dog
see i saw the dog first and then i look
up and i'm like oh god
why would you do that why for the love
of god would you do that
that takes a long ass time to do that as
well why
would you do that you don't just wake up
one day morning and go
i'm gonna crochet not just myself but my
dog
and it's gonna be epic you know if she
did it for the meme
i can understand but you know she didn't
do it for the mean
so there will be no respect for me okay
a long time lurker then i saw this
and just had to share wasn't it god's
name of earth am i looking at okay
those are the eyes
[Music]
why would you make this you know my car
is really nice and all
but i would really prefer it for it to
be a hippo
who says that i just really love
hippos they're so great but really i
want to drive a hippo
don't you understand you don't
understand i love hippos
found on craigslist i have no words
i mean mater is a great character at
least i understand this because
it makes sense to be a fan of that
wonderful film
known as cars 2. yeah i would say this
is actually awesome taste
and great execution good job
this one wins congratulations german
police
stops car with what turns out to be a
blood sticker
no charges because awful taste is not
a crime jesus christ
i like you can you imagine the police
reaction being like we should probably
stop that car
jesus christ you forget really how bad
taste people had
not like me impeccable taste i mean
couldn't be better than than this i
heard you guys might
appreciate this velvet mercedes i saw
jesus christ i've actually seen these i
saw this in
beverly hills i saw a velvet uh was it a
mustang i don't know
it actually looked good this looks
terrible i i don't know what difference
he made
kind of want to pee on that i don't know
what
[Music]
don't judge me okay i like peeing on
things that are ugly
i'm beginning to see a theme here with
the car
changes now why would you do that
why would you do that can i get my brand
new van to look
20 years old thanks
well at least now you don't have to
worry about it aging that actually makes
perfect sense is it distracting that i
have my hand up here because it's quite
comfortable
this is an abomination why would you do
that
i don't understand i just
i just don't understand i need to know
the context
[Laughter]
so the ear goes around the neck i mean
that's clever
does it look good absolutely not is it
clever and funny
yes oh my god yes preach it guys
this is what i'm talking talking about
it's not just this you see a lot of guys
get their beard
like perfect line and perfect
the way the way peop they go to like a
barber and they're like
i'm gonna hook you up we're gonna get
you the best goddamn beard cut ever and
then it just looks like
it looks disgusting it makes me sick are
you telling me they're supposed to look
good do you look
that looks terrible look at this dude
look at this this is what i see this
is oh god no please
awful taste great execution my god is
that jesus christ
jesus of netherence as a balloon
crucifixion i don't know about you guys
but i kind of like it and i at least
appreciate the artistry that went behind
this
i feel like don't you know someone like
this someone's cousin
someone's uncle they're like yeah i had
this passion project that i've been
working on for like 30 years
and you can tell they're talented but
then you look at it you're like
this is awful i saw this on facebook
i don't know this is kind of cool i want
to tell you
did you guys know that uh quiff nikken
is a swedish invention
you're welcome the world it's also
showing your pp
size this reddit makes me uncomfortable
i don't know about you guys
i feel sick this dentist room waiting
the thing is like also all the money
that went into this it's not just the
time
it's like the investments people make to
create these abominations
oh my [ __ ]
god what is that stop
crocheting people
okay that should be banned i would
rather they ban this
than any other bad things murder theft
fine ban this please ban crocheting
people
has anyone ever went hey i would like a
crocheted baby please
i just don't understand i have so many
questions
oh my god what is that teeth oh god
stop just stop this is why people need
to stop being creative
this is why those hug don't hug me i'm
scared videos exist
stop being creative it's not for you man
let's chain ankle crocs
in case someone steals your crocs
gotcha bet you didn't think i wore
it's a stylistic choice now why would
you want that on your chest
oh my god what am i looking at
this whole thing just makes me
uncomfortable i feel sick so much like
if you're feeling sick right now
just so i can know how many people there
they are there they are i
comment about these they're like four
thousand yeah
i i remember asking in the video who on
god's earth
with the right mind would get one of
these
and then literally the day after filthy
frank's cousin
i don't know if he actually is his
cousin there's a tweet saying oh yeah
ezra is my cousin that's a pretty known
fact
why would you do that
the balls the balls to pull up on one of
these
that's some huge balls okay i can
appreciate
that i can only appreciate it for the
meme but i can't tell if he's memeing
all reality filthy frank i don't know
what to tell you man
a duct tape car
jesus christ i mean it looks smooth
i know what to tell you man awful taste
great great execution
you did a good job you taped your car oh
god this makes me sick i feel so weird
what is that oh oh
and i agree i hate it i hate it
it's so impressive but i hate it what in
the god's name is that
she has a drawer on her shoe
uh no she has chocolates in it what does
she have
she has any chocolates in her shoe
oh god i mean why not i mean why not at
this point
why the frick not this upside down truck
stop stop it
stop it i mean that looks dope no does
that not look dope
i think that looks dope does that mean i
have awful taste
what is this doggy doo doo firework oh
god i really want to see this
okay come out it does of course
that's awesome
oh my god this is me when i have mexican
jesus christ this is every edgar has
custom dog slippers made to look like
your dog
i think that dog's face summarizes my
reaction pretty well
i kind of like this i think sometimes i
do have awful tastes
[Laughter]
[Music]
can i have one of those haircuts please
finish the artwork please
it looks good it looks really good i'm
starting to think we need to ban
crocheting just in general just ban
it i'm sorry if you're a fellow crochet
stir
not a fellow crochet sister a
nine-year-old christer is that what it's
called crochet
i'm gonna call it that you're gonna have
to stop we're putting you to prison
there should be some sort of creative
law someone makes some
an abomination they just get thrown to
jail been like sorry this crochet was
just so bad
you're going to prison now you
contribute
nothing therefore you will go to jail
and think about what you've done
lightning mcqueen tron ferrari that
man it's kind of cool god damn it it's
like one of those things where
it might have a personal attachment for
you
and everyone i get it now i think i got
it
it's so yeah that's what it is it's like
one of those things that you have a
personal attachment to
and then maybe the people around you
know that that's the thing that you
really like
so when they get it they're so proud of
it to everyone else around and go like
wow
that's so great we're so proud of you
meanwhile on the internet
[Music]
like this guy he probably likes teeth
you know and he's like
i have this mustang and i really want
tea fun
i don't know i'm trying to make sense of
insane people here
okay god damn it why would you do that
now why would you do that
and why would you give your haircut a
haircut don't give your haircut a
haircut goddammit
stop being creative ah
i can't take it anymore frosted tips oh
god
why does if it's 2019 stop getting
frosted tips
for the love of god
i can't take it anymore lady wanted her
husband's bite mark has it
[ __ ] up
it's disgusting what is that what am i
looking at
i'll see you guys tomorrow oh
before you leave got one important
announcement
90 million club merch have you gotten it
yet it's time
to do your part thank you
represent.contact pewdiepie
see you guys tomorrow bye
thank you for [ __ ]
it's disgusting what is that what am i
looking at tuber simulator
it's now so relevant that it's got a
brand new
minigame craniac drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game
and you say there's more of course there
is new knowledge perks
new quests and new pixellings
and legs guys
[Music]
like